talk us through we've been waiting
haven't we patiently for those findings
into what happened with nordstream uh
what's your read we we have and you're
the Nordstrom won Nordstrom 2 gas
pipelines as you said were
um blown up as the swedes have fined out
and the swedesmen carrying out a
detailed investigation to try and
identify who's done it the Russians are
the uh the favorite the Russians have
denied any involvement they've blamed
the British and the Royal Navy for
getting involved in it but the swedes
have now got conclusive evidence that
there was explosive traces um at the
sites of where the pipelines have been
disrupted those explosive traces
whenever their allies should be able to
tell you
um were the explosives have been
manufactured certainly which country
however it's easy to put a false flag
using explosives so that's probably why
they haven't released that information
at the moment until they can verify it
through other means but this is a
perfect example of Putin's economic war
against Europe and against the west and
we're all suffering from it as we found
find out in the the budget yesterday and
he's continuing to do that he he's uh
also continuing with his economic war
against the Ukrainian people
um and inside Ukraine itself you know
he's attacking energy infrastructure
there so he's hitting us all on all
fronts and how long before we get that
composition analysis and in public
domain do you think that's impossible to
say it's up to the Swedish investigators
um the Swedish investigators you know
they're coming at it from a from a
neutral perspective they're going to
have to look at the different countries
that are that are involved and run it
through
um all of them and they will almost
certainly go to the Russians behind
closed doors and say this is you the the
findings that we've got have you got any
comeback on it
um there's a good chance it might leak
at some stage in there um but
um you we we just don't know when
they're going to conclude this okay
um and talk us through we're going to
get our handy map up on the screen for
you to use as as a tool there Philip
talk us through what is the latest on
the ground yeah the latest on the ground
you know as I mentioned the Russians
have continued their attacks with um
cruise missiles and
um Iran and Kamikaze drones and other
things against
um critical National infrastructure in
particular power plants and water plants
um across Ukraine uh slightly less
missiles last night than we had on that
massive wave which resulted in um the
cross Polish border explosion killing
unfortunately killing two people but
again this is part of Putin's economic
war attack the will of the people
um to try and break the will of the
politicians um to put a real pressure
over over the winter months from a
military perspective from a tactical
perspective the Russians are still
continuing to attack in the bakmut
donesque area and and try and capture
the whole of that donesque oblast which
we can see from the black line
um uh labeled donbass region that's
there to try and get some form of
success they've been doing this for
weeks and they're not achieving very
much what we haven't seen any evidence
of yet is that the troops that the
Russians will have released from giving
up the years on region
actually getting up into that area and
defense intelligence UK defense
intelligence has said that they are
still refurbishing before they do that
and then the ukrainians
um up uh further north
um of buckmut in an area that's the
sabatoni uh criminia line
um are preparing to attack in according
to the Russians we're getting nothing
from the ukrainians but this is Russian
reporting
um we don't know where the next
Ukrainian main effort will be they've
had no other success in Harrison after
they had success up in the car key area
they may switch back to the north again